[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
de francés 24 luis méndez bienvenido
nuevamente a este estudio vamos entonces
a iniciar hablando de la denuncia que
hizo el gobierno ucraniano sobre un robo
de granos por parte de rusia a los 6
raúl lo informó el ministro de
relaciones exteriores de ucrania dmitri
culeba quien advirtió a las naciones
para que no compren productos a su
juicio robados por rusia en un mensaje
en la red social 'twitter' culé indicó
que las fuerzas rusas están robando
granos lo están colocando en barcos y lo
están vendiendo al extranjero por lo que
pidió estos países no comprar dichos
productos ucrania se erige como un
importante productor y exportador de
productos como semilla de girasol base
para entre otras cosas producir aceites
que son comercializados en india y
también el trigo empleado para producir
harina y a su vez pan sobre ello
lituania ha propuesto el establecimiento
de una coalición naval para escoltar los
buques con productos ucranianos a través
del mar negro una propuesta que ha sido
respaldada de acuerdo con el medio
británico the guardian
por el reino unido- luis también le
pregunto que otros organismos se han
sumado a esta preocupación por conseguir
una salida de los granos ucrania
ucranianos para decir que en primer
lugar que desde la crisis en ucrania el
precio de los alimentos se ha
incrementado
y junto a los problemas globales que
existían ya en la cadena de suministro
han generado presión en la inflación en
diversas naciones no obstante la mayor
preocupación de los organismos
internacionales es que se pueda utilizar
este bloqueo a los granos ucranianos
como un arma de guerra escuchemos
[Música]
en la ucrania ocupada por rusia el
ejercito del kremlin está confiscando
las existencias de cereales y las
maquinarias para algunos eso les ha
traído recuerdo del pasado oscuro los
tiempos de las incautaciones de las
cosechas en la época soviética y la
hambruna devastadora de 1930
y hoy la artillería rusa está
bombardeando almacenes de granos en toda
ucrania deliberadamente y los buques de
guerra rusos en el mar negro están
bloqueando el paso de barcos ucranianos
llenos de trigo y semillas de girasol a
bloque
whitten sunflower seeds louis ni fue
presentado al índice de desarrollo
turístico del año 2021 así es raúl este
entre otras cosas reveló un leve
incremento del sector en el año 2021
luego de verse afectado por la pandemia
un año antes pero entre sus conclusiones
se establece a grandes rasgos el
potencial sin explotar del turismo
especialmente en países en desarrollo
japón se ubica a la cabeza entre las 10
economías que permiten el desarrollo del
sector por su parte eeuu es la única
americana entre las diez naciones
precisamente sobre japón
la publicación qatarí al yazira que citó
un informe de bloomberg destaca que los
operadores turísticos del archipiélago
están preocupados con el plan turismo de
prueba establecido en el país y donde
solamente 50 visitantes de 4 países
podrán participar de recorridos
organizados por agencias seleccionadas
pero siguiendo en asia y en otro tema
hablamos de la empresa hervía en mi que
estaría pensando en cerrar su negocio en
china todo esto en medio de los bloqueos
por los nuevos brotes de kobe 19 vamos
ahora a hablar de argentina porque hay
cambios a nivel de gabinete económico
del gobierno de alberto fernández no así
de raúl este lunes se conoció sobre la
renuncia del secretario de comercio
interior roberto feletti quien dejó su
cargo a la orden luego de una
conversación con el ministro de economía
martín guzmán la noticia que se presenta
en medio de una alta inflación en el
país y también dentro del programa
precios cuidados establecidos por el
gobierno de fernández para
controlar la inflación que desde enero
hasta abril ha presentado aumentos
considerables se ha mostrado como una
expectativa dentro de los el bloque de
empresarios que están atentos a lo que
pudiesen surgir con las nuevas
conversaciones ya el ministro guzmán ha
adelantado que podrían generar algunos
incentivos para los empresarios y ellos
podría influir en la reducción de la
inflación en argentina es gracias como
siempre por toda la información
económica viajamos directo sin escalas
hasta parís ahí nos está esperando eric
olavarría para hablar de la actualidad
francesa